[Music]
protons started cheerfully in front of
the Rex Museum in Amsterdam hundreds of
protesters gathered to demand the
government East lockdown restrictions
and lift the curfew the first in the
country since World War II the
Netherlands with a population of 17
million has had nearly 1 million
infections since the start of the
pandemic and around 15 000 deaths there
is a disease we're not denying anything
but
the rules are destroying lives economies
suicides are going up it's a disaster
the threat is that we lose our freedoms
freedoms we've fought for a long time
and we should we should not give them
away this easily
to this Birth by police but these orders
were ignored
in Vienna the anti-lockdown March turned
political with supporters of the
far-right Freedom Party dominating the
rally in the Austrian capital
in Brussels police prevented people from
Gathering and started arresting them
before the rally could start
and in Budapest restaurant workers took
to the streets urging the government to
open up their businesses
many people have lost their jobs
hundreds of thousands have been left in
insecurity can we still have any doubt
that politicians have made responsible
decisions governments across Europe have
been accused of being slow to act at the
start of the pandemic one year on as
cases searched they have been forced to
impose much tougher measures the
situation has been compounded by
frustrations over the slow rollout of
vaccines police are not taking any
chances here in the heart of Amsterdam
they're confronted by a small group of
protesters but police is trying very
hard to prevent the scenario that
happened last week when thousands were
rioting in cities across the Netherlands
[Music]
after some protesters started throwing
stones and letting off fireworks police
on Horseback moved in to clear the area
around 30 people were detained potasses
have failed to continue their actions
until the 9 pm curfew is lifted step
fast and Al Jazeera Amsterdam